hello everyone and welcome to a very
very special game app from the Warsaw
Olympiad in 1935 it's a game between
Paul quieres and William Winter now this
is the first game we're showing by uh
William Winter but there's a very
special reason I chose this one there we
have a marriage proposal in today's
video uh but we're gonna get to that as
I usually uh deal with that at the end
of the of the actual chess but one of
the reasons why I chose such a such a
romantic game and uh well okay Paul
Karis um he played many styles he was
mostly known for his con a great
counter-attacking abilities and he
played pretty much every great chess
player that that ever lived okay he
didn't play uh he didn't play Tiny scene
play Alaska but he he played everyone
from capablanca Alien all the way to
Bobby Fischer and even Anatoly karpov
and had great results against all of
them I think he even defeated uh most of
them and uh okay he didn't have a
positive record against Bobby fisch her
he had like uh Fisher defeated him four
times uh Karis defeated Fisher three
times in they drew three games but uh I
mean all in all uh spectacular player
throughout his entire life also one of
the reasons why he's considered uh or
rather called uh uh krsd Eternal second
as uh he was always on top of the Chess
World but there was always that one
player that was better than he was it
Bobby Fischer mikaltal or maybe
capablanca or Al yankin or I mean anyone
who is considered an absolute Legend but
uh he was able to withstand the the test
of time to the fullest and he played the
you know with all of them and defeated
all of them so although not a world
champion himself I believe at least as
far as a chess channels are concerned uh
Paul quieres does not need any
additional introduction but he okay his
opponent is William Winter a very strong
player himself and usually a player of
very sound style he does not uh go for
any crazy attacking
ideas or some wild sacrifices is but
this game he maybe goes he breaks the
principles a little too much and again
someone like Paul Pierce that will not
uh go as planned and winter defeated
some very strong players in his own
right he defeated nimsovich he defeated
doctor of Milan weed Mark he defeated
bronstein he defeated uh Sultan Khan so
many many great players and he was even
uh I didn't notice he was a cousin of
James Matthew Berry the creator of Peter
Pan if someone is interested in that but
yeah let's uh check out the game it's
quite a nice one 1935 the war so
Olympiad and Karis has the white pieces
he opens with Pawn to E4 and we have C5
by winter uh going for the Sicilian
Defense with Knight to F3 and now
Knights the F6 going for the NIMS of
each variation of the Cillian and
although you will not see this line a
lot nowadays it's maybe the sixth or
seventh most popular move for black it
has been played by some very very strong
players for example mama played it quite
extensively against every top player in
the world and he had great results with
it so okay Ponte E5 you you can play
Knight to C3 or Pawn D5 those are the
main options for white so Pawn to E5 uh
as in 1935 you uh if you're allowed to
go forward with the pawn you you take
that opportunity Knights the D5 and now
Knight to C3 and here while you could
capture on C3 uh maybe this would be
giving uh Keras a bit too much he has a
very natural developing squares for for
his pieces and you haven't really gained
all that much if anything you will allow
him the castle Queen side very quickly
so instead we have Pawn to E6 uh
defending the Knight and now comes
Knight captures on D5 we have e captures
on D5 and the D4 and this is all pretty
much standard Theory even in 2022 today
but nowadays Knight to C6 is the main
move here and my major I've played this
like I said he played it against Wesley
so he played against kariaki he played
against une he played it against Anand
and he never lost a game in this he even
defeated kariakin last year in the
Magnus Crossing Invitational but okay
here we have D6 not Knight to C6 and now
Bishop to G5 Karis goes after the black
queen winter goes Queen to A5 check and
now while he could go back uh okay we
already developed the bishop and G5 it's
very nicely placed there just Pawn to C3
now comes C characters on D4 now winter
asks how are you recapturing you cannot
recapture with the pawn the pawn is
pinned you can play Knight captures or
you can play Queen captures uh on D4 but
the uh Karis does none of that he plays
Bishop to D3 I will just show uh how
rich the position is you can even play
E6 here it's such a crazy move but uh
how how can black react to this of
course you don't want to allow uh e-cap
prison uh on F7 and if you play Bishop
captures on E6 then Knight captures on
D4 uh will come with an attack on that
Bishop so basically F captures an E6
should be played Knight captures on D4
and not Knight the C6 and Bishop to B5
and you get some very very uh cool
options here for both sides for example
if Bush up to D7 you just castle and now
if Knight captures on D4 you play Bishop
captures on D7 King captures and queen
captures on D4 leaving black with a king
and D7 it's not lost for black black
still has a very strong Center and if
black is able to develop with some
Bishop to E7 moves uh then of course it
should be possible but Queen captures on
G7 white should always be better however
if you want to play this you can in the
game Keras played Bishop to D3 and now
we have D characters in C3 okay we are
now threatening some very nasty stuff if
check comes with a c capture some B2 but
care is just nicely castles here and
okay you've grabbed some points you
really grabbed some pawns you should
just say okay enough with the pawn
grabbing let's call it a day let's
continue developing something like
Knight to C6 maybe and then if Rook D1
seems like there there is no good way to
defend this you can you can defend with
Bishop to E6 so that's how black should
continue and now okay let's say B
captures and C3 not a lot of ways for
white to continue the attack now we're
gonna play Queen to C7 uh threaten D
captures on E5 and after white captures
you will develop the dark Square bishop
and so on now if Bishop to F5 you will
happily give back the pawn just the uh
Castle to safety let's say captures
captures and captures and you would get
something like this where black has a
very nice Queen Bishop battery here you
have the uh the semi-open file for The
Rook you can bring the other Rook into
the game it's a very nice position for
black
uh but in the game uh William Winter who
like I said before we started the game
was known to be a very sound a very very
strong positional player uh played C
captures on B2 it's uh maybe a bit too
much uh to go for and uh how do you
continue it seems like uh you should be
able to do it because it comes with
Tempo uh but look at this now Rook to B1
and now D captures on E5 and how do you
how do you play this Knight captures on
E5 and now Bishop to D6 this is what
William Winter saw when he decided to
capture another pawn and now he says all
right let's castle and I'm just gonna be
up too many pawns and beat this Paul
carries guy whoever he is uh but uh well
that could not be further from the truth
as to what will happen in the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for uh for
uh for Keras uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always going uh
for the attack and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on F7 so congratulations to
everyone who found that uh just for fun
I will show another winning line it's
not uh I mean it's just as a winning but
Knight captures and F7 is uh is stronger
and faster you could also play Rook to
E1 it seems like it does nothing because
black can just Castle to safety uh but
not really black castles here you still
play Knight captures on F7 and now
there's really nothing to do if you
capture with the King it's just a matter
of a very quick Checkmate Queen H5 check
King goes to G8 and now Queen captures
King to F7 and now Bishop to G6 will be
checkmate with the rook and Bishop doing
a fine job of covering that e-file so
what you could do after Knight captures
an F7 is captured with the Rook but this
will not help you all that much now you
will get Rook to E8 with check Rook to
f8 and now Queen to H5 again not much to
be done here whatever you play you're
just gonna get destroyed if H6 Bishop
captures if you capture then Queen to G6
if you go back with the queen uh Queen
characters on D5 and that's uh pretty
much it if King Tay trade even Bishop
captures on G7 is enough uh as black
cannot counter white along the light
squares for example Queen captures Queen
to H5 with check and now after King the
Jade Bishop C for check and there are no
moves for black you can give up a few
pieces but that's pretty much it black
should resign here so uh after Bishop to
D6 the game can be won with Rook D1 it's
a silent move but uh the the end result
will be the same but Knight captures an
F7 the move that uh care split is much
much quicker because now uh it seems
like it doesn't really do all that much
you could even Castle saying okay I'm
just gonna Castle your your free to
gobble up my Bishop on D6 but white will
just continue with Queen to H5 and
pretty much uh it's uh the same thing if
real characters and F7 just a nice Queen
to H7 checking to a f8 and now Queen to
AJ to Checkmate as the bishop covers the
E7 square and even if you don't capture
the Knight if you play G6 we just gobble
up everything Bishop captures and G6 now
if captures captures any flow captures
on F7 you can still play Bishop captures
uh on F7 with Chair King G7 and now even
Bishop to E6 is enough to Checkmate the
black king because the bishop captures
an E6 Queen day not that obviously it's
not uh it's not that romantic Queen to
H6 check King to F7 and now Queen to F6
with checking the E8 you will capture a
piece here King to f8 and now Bishop to
H6 with a very nice Queen bishop
checkmate so that's what happens if you
try the castle after Knight captures on
F7 so you have to capture it there's
nothing uh other than capturing so King
captures on F7 and now comes Queen to H5
with check and again how do you play
this uh the problem is if you move the
king if you go to G8 then even Queen the
E8 check so King to f8 is the only good
option now Rook beat the E1 threatening
mate in one and once you defended this
just Rook to E3 and there's no defense
against Rook to F3 check that's just uh
that that's just it so instead after
Queen to H5 check G6 was played uh seems
like it should work but uh the problem
is there's Bishop captures on G6 look at
this age captures on G6 Queen to h8 and
now black gains the move it seems like
black can defend this and black plays
Bishop to F5 it uh uh cuts off the the
the the the white piece from the app
file also attacks the rook and B1 and
here just Rook F to E1 another
spectacular attacking move by Keras uh
just uh you know a very silent move but
it completely locks out the the black
king from escaping via the D file and
now even if black was to go so far as to
give up the queen for two Rooks let's
say queen captures anyone check real
captors and now B1 Queen you don't have
to capture and allow a black to take
your Rook you can just play Queen H7
check and The Rook controls the E file
that's basically the only thing you
wanted when you first played Rook after
E1 King f8 and now Bishop to H6 another
spectacular Checkmate so I have to look
at the one Bishop to E4 now closing of
the E file but not just Rook captures on
e4
uh Queen to F6 check would also get the
job done but Karis prefers The Rook
captures on e4 D captures an E4 and now
Queen to F6 with check and it was in
this position on move 19 and that
William Winter resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is uh once you move the king
let's say you go King to G8 uh just
Queen captures and G6 you will grab a
few pieces Queen captures on D6 and now
you will just Checkmate the black king
queen t7 tracking the G8 and Bishop to
F6 and there is no defense against Queen
to G7 Checkmate you could postpone the
game with some silly moves but okay
we're not gonna play those and if you
don't go King the uh G8 if you go King
to E8 it's not much better just Queen
the E6 with checking f8 and now again
another beautiful Bishop Queen checkmate
with Bishop to H6 Checkmate so uh
although not a another game you would
usually see by the great power quieres
but we've seen uh many many times now as
we've covered these games also many
times on the channel that he will play
any style you want you you you you you
try attacking he will defend you try to
defend he will attack you you try to
grab a pawn to many he will just
completely Crush you up until this point
he was still very much playable for
black uh but after C captures on B2
there was just no way to to play this uh
although it seems like you should be
able because uh he really calculated it
well d-capters and E5 Knight captured
Bishop D6 it seems like you're you're
one move away from castling uh but not
really Knight captures on F7 and that's
it that's all there is to this game uh
so yeah beautiful stuff and um I I I'm
very happy that uh Mr Mr Doug decided to
propose the uh tarepka uh via this
channel as it allowed us to show a very
nice romantic game from 1935. uh We've
covered a lot of uh modern games uh for
for the past month or two uh so you know
a change of pace is always more than
welcome uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh I would like to
thank um uh Doug well or rather uh
propose in his name terebka will you
marry me repka from Doug and get this uh
he says that they met while he was
giving free chess lesson uh in uh in a
local bar uh so uh you know if you guys
uh want to meet someone go to local bar
give out some free lessons uh you know
good things might happen uh so all the
all the best to uh Ripka and the dog and
I would like to thank pretty much filigo
in 1984 uh dww and uh Simon Johnson for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day